is coming up with youtube
video ideas hard do you feel like you
struggle when it comes to
titling your videos well in this video
my i'm going to walk you through
three of our guaranteed titles to get
you views that we've used here at think
media to get over 85
million views if we're just meeting my
name is heather torres
and this is the think marketing q a and
we're gonna jump right into it we're
gonna go right into
the three irresistible youtube titles
guaranteed to get you
views number one just to let you know
this is actually coming from
our uh think media youtube title
formula guy that is part of our youtube
starter kit and the first one is before
you x watch this before you
x watch this now what does that even
mean well
here are some examples for you of how
you can use
this title before you start on youtube
before you start a youtube channel
watch this you'll notice we do this
quite a bit here at think
here's another one before you homeschool
watch
this and i love this one this is from j
shetty before you go to sleep
watch this now why is this important why
should you do a watch this well if you
want to become an authority in
your niche if you want to be coming if
you want to become someone
that people are uh looking up to um that
you are able to influence
you want to make something that before
they start doing x before they
you know start the ketogenic diet before
they start
renovating an rv before they get start
using a macbook pro you want to be the
person
that they go to and by having a video
like this it'll
peak curiosity it'll help you position
yourself
as an authority and you can also then
give educational tips throughout those
videos all right that's title number one
we're gonna walk through the next two
the next one is uh if you
wanna do this title this versus that
this versus that title here's an example
of that
vitamix versus blendtec for 2020. now
they update these different types of
blenders
uh and this is such a great video
because people are actually in a
buying mode when they're actually
searching two different products to
compare them against each other
they're in a buying mode so this is a a
very valuable and
powerful title idea to be able to get
views when people are starting to search
for things here's another one i just did
this one apple pencil one versus apple
pencil two
i'm using my tablet to take notes for a
lot of things my kids are just going
back to school
and so i was researching should i
upgrade to the two or should
i stick with the one look at this video
from a year ago
has 700 000 views on it are you seeing
the power of being able to do a versus
video here's another video that i did on
my homeschool channel
uh homeschooling versus public schooling
five differences
107 000 views
this versus that and i love this one too
this one is
techno dad who's one of our students
inside of video ranking academy
av receiver versus amplifier av
receiver versus amplifier i don't even
know what those two things are
but i guess 94 000 people are searching
for this exact
video a versus video is extremely
powerful because it allows you to
compare two different things
for people that are in a buying mode
when they are searching
two different things they are possibly
going to buy something so you could be
the last stop
before they make that purchase so if you
have your affiliate marketing set up
you're able to actually get a commission
on those
purchases you're seeing this the value
of being able to make these kinds of
videos
all right well here is something before
we get into the last
title i want to let you know about our
uh
free youtube influence challenge that we
have coming up
in the next week i'd love for you to
register for this if you are looking at
starting or growing a youtube channel
this year we're hosting a seven day
challenge here at
think where we're going to be walking
you through seven different
days of value-packed content this is
gonna be
a time for you to uh to go all in with
your youtube channel to
have you uh work through different um
steps that we're gonna be sharing with
you
this is gonna be happening live for
seven days in our
youtube influence challenge you can get
registered at
tubeinfluence.com if that is something
you are interested
in all right let's get into the last tip
the last tip is the how-to tip the
how-to
tip here's a video how to uh
need how to do no need
sandwich bread say that five times fast
this is
mary a merit from there this is mary
from mary's nest
i'm having trouble talking today i'm
like i had way too much caffeine or
something happen
uh this is mary from mary's nest and she
is one of our video ranking academy
students and mary made this video
600 000 people are interested in how to
make
no need sandwich bread this is a
powerful title because you're able to
really hone in on what your audience is
asking for
i love this one too from ben from keto
camp ben was just on the think marketing
podcast
he did one about how to lose weight fast
with the ketogenic
diet how to lose weight fast with the
ketogenic diet
i like it because he also has five
advanced tips that he's able to
give in this video here's another one
from techno dad
home how to connect speakers to
amplifiers this is a step-by-step
walkthrough of how to do that and you'll
notice
600 000 people are interested in this
exact
thing and the last one how to make
oil paint dry faster did you even know
that was a thing
i didn't but artists obviously are
searching this because allison
from video ranking academy made this
video and 6 000 people
have searched that and then the last one
is
our uh video that we have at think media
how to make a youtube video on your
phone this video just surpassed
1 million views it's a how-to video a
step-by-step video
this is extremely powerful for your
brand if you're gonna be making videos
this year you should make these three
videos and then make them over
and over and over i want you to get a
journal i want you to write out
what how-to video could i do what versus
video could i do
what two products could i compare and
then think about
what you could do over and over and over
when you're making videos we do this
here at think media we compare two
different cameras together
we go through and we compare how to
i'm sorry we compare like different
microphones together we do
how-to videos on walking you through um
different software that you could be
using this is super powerful for your
brand
and i hope that those three titles are
titles that you will do
this year on your channel well we're
gonna jump into
the q a part of today's video and i have
my co-host of the think marketing
podcast sean
cannell with me how you doing sean man
i'm fired up heather
those are three super powerful titles
and of course if you're just joining the
video
you can catch the replay here on the
channel make sure you implement all of
those if you're
thinking about if you're planning to
bake christmas
cookies watch this before you bake a
cake watch this
or the versus strategy super powerful
strategies
and um excited about the challenge too
heather uh
walking through the ashes says what's
the link for the challenge
tubeinfluence.com is the link and of
course in the description down below
this video
um it would have made sense for us to
post it there but we had we will post it
in the comments so it's
www.tubeinfluence.com
and uh you could check that out to
register for free that's going to be
amazing
and then if you want to join us on the
show um i'm dropping the link right now
and we are going to bring some of you on
for some q a today and uh
we have nicole with us actually so
nicole how's it going how can we help
where are you watching from what's your
channel about
hello um i don't know if you can hear me
or not
yep we can nicole i'm good thank you
um so my channel is a sewing channel
i have um 55 000 subscribers
and i'm trying to convert my channel to
a coaching channel
but still have sewing on the side so i
didn't know what the best way was to do
that
yeah really great question nicole uh one
thing
uh that you want to always remember when
you are putting out content on youtube
is that you don't want to make videos
that people didn't subscribe for so if
you have a channel that is about sewing
and now you're pivoting that channel
into coaching
one of two things is gonna happen you're
either gonna lose
subscribers right so you'll have
subscribers that don't wanna watch
anymore
um but two you can be confusing the
viewers that are currently there so if
you're gonna be pivoting to
coaching um i would actually suggest not
having it on that channel unless are you
are you
coaching and sewing or you're like
pivoting fully out of coaching i mean
out of sewing
yeah that's a great question so i'm
mixing it in
i have um sewing i have coaching sewing
and then i coach people that want to
um sew for a living and that kind of
stuff so it's all like in the niche
great i don't know if that's what the
best way is to do that without starting
a new channel
yes okay so i retract everything i just
said because
you're doing a channel that's still
around coaching i mean that's still
around
sewing so it's still around that same
niche now uh
here's one thing when you're making that
content um are you noticing
that you're getting less views on those
videos i haven't started doing it yet i
haven't
i have a private coaching group and i
haven't i'm doing
um i i follow stu mclaren's tribe thing
and
and so i'm i'm i'm gonna be rolling this
out in october
um but i'm just trying to prep for it
and i wanted to know the best way to
kind of like
introduce this without being like hey
i'm doing a whole brand switch and
and that kind of stuff so i i know that
not all of my subscribers watch every
single video that's very obvious with
with my statistics so i didn't know um
you know i'm just kind of looking for
some general advice i guess
great okay i should have asked all those
questions at the beginning before i
spouted out advice to you nicole um one
thing first
i think this is so cool what you're
doing because i think this is
a niche that's probably underserved
right like there's a lot of people that
are
are sewing but not actually like getting
the coaching along with it so
um the way you can start pivoting it is
are you
seating it in your content that's the
first thing you'd want to do so start
seating that that's another authority
builder that you do
so uh i'm nicole um you know i teach
this type of sewing i'm also the founder
of xyz
group where we go deeper into x y and z
like you can
yeah and i was watching um i was
watching
i think your channel doing that also
where you talk about the tips of the
different cameras and
lighting and stuff like that and then go
check out my
xyz membership so i was i was liking how
that was
that was a subtle but still um
information about that so i like that
yeah and and when you start doing that
you can
make some one-off videos that are
explainer videos because i think one
thing that we miss is the idea that
if we're gonna make a pivot we should
tell our audience like it's okay
to make that video that says hey i'm
super excited because i'm launching
x y and z and when this happens
here's how you can get involved and that
might not be a viral video but it's just
educating your audience as to what
you're doing
so um how you can also make different
videos around that is
exactly how we do it here we will talk
about how to make money on youtube well
not everyone on our channel is very
interested in that but when we're making
those videos
we always see that we we help you with
the tech
and the tools we talk about our
different programs that we offer here at
think media
but we're not doing it in a aggressive
way
it's very passive it's just an authority
builder of what we're doing
and let me tell you nicole when you
start seeding that over and over and
over
the people that are interested will
raise their hand right
and so that's where you'll start to gain
momentum in that i love that you're in
stu mclaren's because he teaches all
about how to do membership groups right
we have a membership group here at think
media it's called inner circle
and so what we've done is we actually
have put out some of our
classes that we've given that we've done
inside of inside of inner circle
we've given out bits and pieces of that
on our channel
so it just sees the content as to what's
happening and you can do that too
especially because it's even aligned
with what you're actually doing does
that give you any help nicole
yeah i really liked how you were talking
about seating the content
that's a great way to um you know add
value into my funnel and um so i'm going
to start doing that thank you
amazing and don't forget nicole always
be talking to your audience and asking
them what they want because when they
start feeding you those titles when they
start feeding you those pain points
your solution can also be hey
i also have this membership group so
your solution can be that
so always be talking to your audience
and getting that advice from them
getting what their
pain points are because i'll bet your
solution in that coaching program is a
big one
that they don't even know about yet so
if someone comes to you and says this is
my pain point
and you say this is my solution
you've now become the trusted advisor to
help them on their path
thank you i i really liked um the topics
or the tips that i was getting from
some of the videos on your channel about
vid iq i've i've looked that up and
and started getting some information on
that's helpful too so thanks for all of
your free tips and all the advice you're
giving me today
amazing and nicole make sure you sign up
for the free youtube challenge it's free
for seven days so make sure you sign up
for that
yes awesome well thanks for being on the
show today
wow super powerful heather amazing
advice nicole thanks for coming on the
show if you're getting value already too
or just joining smash the like button
because we're going to be doing some
more q a couple
uh rapid fire questions here jonathan
asked
should you always use the three title
tactics that heather
talked about in this video and a couple
practical tips
um you should always use a powerful
title
titles are so important you should
always use one of those
tactics per video you don't really want
to necessarily each one kind of
lives in its own orbit and again heather
was teaching out of our
title guide where we talk about 15
different title formulas those were
three of them
and so one title one video you really
want to take time crafting your title
we wrote three or four different titles
for this video
we've got a video coming up tomorrow on
think media i brainstormed like four or
five different titles
but we really lean on our guide to think
about which one is the most powerful and
then i bounce those off of
heather or tony on the think media team
or mel you might want to bounce them off
a friend or somebody
in a facebook group and say hey which
one of these like makes you want to
click the most
because titles are so important and then
jonathan followed up and said but i'm
curious
out of the formula like should at least
50 of your videos be one of these three
no i would say 50 i mean 100 of your
videos should be one of the 15
and once you kind of know the different
options and the most powerful titles to
choose from
then you figure out how you're going to
position your video jonathan
so that it can have maximum impact and
so
um we have derek coming up and then jay
on the show
um coming up next but derek man how's it
going where are you watching from what's
your channel about
and uh how can we help today today all
right i'm watching from memphis
tennessee i actually have a couple of
channels um i have my
my personal channel which is behind the
cache which is about geocaching
but my my wife also has a channel called
my spectrum life
which is about autism moms and we
doing a live video podcast with that
she's been doing that since
i think february we're really trying to
get it to build momentum
but it's just not building as much as
what we were hoping just want some maybe
some other tips that we could do
with building audience yeah and this is
the channel right my spectrum life right
here
right got it so um
a couple things that i see right off the
bat you know i would encourage you
not to put this is good for the topic of
the day too
my spectrum life even in the title and
definitely not the first thing in the
title
okay because that's the name of the
channel but that may or may not i
actually think that it probably would be
clear to your viewers
but um that's it it's not necessarily
adding to the promise of the title so
even what heather was teaching at the
beginning
you might want to talk about something
uh
that well that you want to use every
word in the title and make it super
super powerful
and so pull that either out of the title
or put at the end of the title but i
would say just pull it out of the title
and a lot of times if we look at like
think media
um and we could look at some you know
success leaves clues and we've had some
really powerful videos today's video is
doing really well
the proven formula for getting more
views and increasing watch time it's
desire based we don't put think media in
the title right
um how to get views fast our our way of
using sentence case
or title case and certain capitalized
words we want to get attention right we
want to see people
that how to format any sd memory card
how to
my friends is another really powerful um
title so
be thinking about i think that's the
immediately thing thing that jumped off
the page and
i want to pass it to heather next but
even you know maybe
how to get your kids to sleep
when dealing with a particular um you
know thing that they're facing or
whatnot and so
and then of course be really doing have
you joined the challenge yet derek
yeah we've both my wife and i have
joined the challenge and
sorry excuse me and i'm also already
signed up for growth video live as well
so oh awesome awesome um and so
i'm trying to think about you know uh
heather i'd love for you to jump in here
too on some thoughts
the other thing is initially you really
are just starting
and so five videos in don't be thinking
too much like well i haven't really got
traction yet you know i mean like
i've been like lifting these kettlebells
for only three days
and i haven't got biceps yet like i get
close my arms are pretty skinny still so
you know it does take time to get
momentum but heather what are some of
your thoughts
yeah first eric i just want to say thank
you so much for the work that you and
your wife are doing stepping into that
space because
it's so needed um for parents to connect
with
parents and so that's my my goal for you
guys would be
uh and my challenge would be are you in
the community
hearing what people are saying so i know
that this is a large community
um you know there's a lot of different
books on this there's organizations
there's other podcasts there's other
youtube channels this is the type of
community that
rallies around each other and so one
thing i would really recommend doing
is what are the 10 to 15 books that a
new parent who's just discovered that
their kid is on the spectrum
anywhere on the spectrum they've now
done the testing or or what about the
testing you know what does that process
look like and what what's your journey
and your story through that
um in respect to as much your privacy
that you'd want to share about
your child but at the same time thinking
about where those parents are
you know usually our audience is just a
few steps behind
where we are if we're helping them along
on a journey
and so derek i would really recommend
you and your wife sitting down and
thinking
what are the top 10 podcasts right now
and i would go to their podcast and i
would look at the titles
of their podcast and i would say we can
make a video on that
we could do a video on that and let's
see if that person
wants to be on our podcast let's
collaborate and see if they want to
share
that tip that they shared on theirs on
our podcast
then i would think about the books then
i would think about the organizations i
would think about um
is there is there anyone online um
what are the opposing sides i know you
know especially in this space there's so
many opposing things in terms of
vaccinations causing it versus being
born with it you know there's so many
different
um there's so many different stances on
it leaning into that and stamping your
flag as to where you are
could be a really big big thing i would
think about what are the blogs
that people are reading what are the
magazines where are the where are you
guys finding your resources
and then let's talk about those that
would be one of the main things and then
i would just say
this is a journey like sean said even if
you have 10
15 30 videos usually a channel doesn't
pop off it doesn't start to really gain
momentum and traction
until you're past 50 and into a hundred
so if derek if you guys are committed to
not only helping
your family but other families and
that's your bigger mission
i really think that you have something
here and that if you stick with it
that you'll see that um come to come to
fruition
right and i know we use strain yard and
we the youtube part of it hasn't gained
as much as the
the facebook has so so that's that's
what we're trying to build more of the
youtube area of it too
so i would join every facebook group
i would be searching the hashtag on
social media i want you to be
in this community listening be really
listening to what are their struggles
what are their pain points what are they
asking for where are they going for
resources
you want to become a detective of those
parents so that you can then service
them in the way that you know they need
to be
all right great thank you yes derek i'm
so excited for you to come to grow with
video live this year we have
some amazing things happening and the
challenge is going to be awesome i'm so
grateful that you and your wife are
connected in the community yeah i've
been wanting to go for several years and
just with
one of the benefits of cove at this time
was actually getting to go through
online
so yeah yeah we'll block the days it's
going to be
epic oh yeah i'm excited thanks derek
thank you appreciate you derek thank you
hey if you've been getting value out of
some of the uh advice
smash the like button it's great to see
everyone here a couple
questions and then we're going to be
bringing jay hay in on the show
uh shelley asked when you were just
starting how important are keywords are
titles more important than keywords
um those are not two conflicting things
titles are incredibly
keywords are incredibly important when
you're just starting
because a keyword and i actually would
just recommend check out the most recent
video that i did
over on think media that was about
um about keywords that exact topic and
really what a keyword is
is probably going to be something like
let's say you had a cooking channel
it'd be called a keyword phrase and it
would be like how to cook
a steak that is a keyword phrase so
that's very important
um and then the title itself you could
maybe make that a lot better you could
be like
how to cook a steak in an oven
parentheses
the the right way for the most flavor
and you'd have keywords
and you'd have kind of like well i want
the right way and i want the most flavor
you'd also be talking to both the search
algorithm as well as
humans that want some tasty steak and so
that's kind of um
a tip on that one and if you check out
think media
the new video out now it's how to get
views fast
with youtube keyword research you're not
going to want to miss that one
that one came out on our other channel
think media and then
sasha j asked how do you
get the hashtags under the video and all
you have to do to get hashtags
underneath your video
is type them into the description
anywhere
and whatever the first three hashtags in
your description
are those are going to be the hashtags
that are under
your video so think media think
marketing and sean cannell are the
hashtags under this video
the reason they show up there is because
down here in the description
they're just typed in there and that's
all you got to do and you can use any
hashtags that you want now quick tip
as we get ready for j and that is
we our philosophy on hashtags is using
them for branding and not necessarily
search
because if you were to type in something
even like how to
cook a steak probably not a lot of
people even really using that but
but the types of videos you're gonna get
are you know like this one ranks but
it's not getting a ton of views and it's
two months old so we haven't really
known hashtags to drive
traffic so what we use hashtags
for is branding so that's why under this
video it says think media
when you click think media you're going
to be able to like go down the rabbit
hole of think media
when you click click think marketing
again you're going to be able to go down
the rabbit hole
of the think marketing channel and you
want to think about it sometimes if
someone clicks a hashtag under your
video it might
take them away from your content so we
use it this is interesting right because
now
someone could thread sean cannell and
maybe watch some of the interviews some
of the other
content but a lot of our own content
that is out there
and so as we land the plane on that tip
um
heather has a really great video that
just dropped on the other channel
heather taurus again when you click that
you sort of get a branded hashtag
of this live right now of her homeschool
channel
of some of the different things she's
been doing so our kind of philosophy
you can experiment with using them to
try to get views but i think they're
best
for kind of grant branding and
organizing
your content hey jay welcome to the
think marketing q a
um tell us what your channel is about
and uh where are you streaming to us
from today
okay hi guys um i'm jay hey i'm from
chicago illinois
and my channel is kind of like positive
um being mentally positive and
internally
happy with yourself and i just want to
help teens around my
age and help them out
awesome what's your question for us
today jay um i wanted to know like how
to promote my channel and get like a
good amount of views because i haven't
really got much
i started a couple weeks ago
and yeah awesome well congratulations on
getting started jay that actually is one
of the hardest parts for creators to do
so i want to congratulate you
for getting started now i see you've got
a handful of videos which is so good you
know in that first year jay
it really is about the experimental
phase
you get to see what kind of videos you
like to create you get to
start to get to know your audience and
what they like to watch
and you're really in this space of um of
just
experimenting i'm loving look at the the
editing sean
i mean what are look at this this is
great so
here's one thing i want you to think
about jay um i want you to start
thinking about what am i
skilled at what am i proficient at i
know
that even as a young person you already
have gifts and abilities and talents
right like there's already things that
you already are good at aren't there
yeah i like um do baking and a lot of
healthy like recipes on my channel
too i love that so here's one thing i
want you to think about as you are
starting to create more and more content
i want you to think about where are my
skills and abilities
how can i really help someone because
did you know jay
even when you're doing cooking videos
you can be sharing positivity
you can be sharing positive mindset you
could be sharing those values
that's a value so you could be sharing
that through
what you are actually skilled and
proficient at so as you're starting to
create
more and more content i want you to
think about who am i here to help
and how do i want to help them and
here's the real one i want you to really
think about jay
what is their pain point usually people
aren't coming to youtube typing in how
can i be more positive
usually they're coming with some type of
a struggle or some type of a pain point
and you can show up as the trusted
friend on the other side
so i would i would do this jay i want
you to get a focus group
of people you want to help so this could
be some other friends this could
be on social media but i want you to ask
them things like hey
sean did this um what do you think i'm
good at like
when you think about when i think about
sean cannell i'm like he's the camera
guy so
if i have a question about a camera i'm
gonna go to sean i'm the homeschool mom
if anyone has questions about homeschool
they're blowing my dms up okay so i want
you to get a focus group and i want them
to speak into you and say jay you know
what you are really good at cooking
you're so positive
i love your healthy recipes i love what
you're doing and then i want you to ask
them hey what would you search
in the youtube search bar because when
they start handing you those things
that's the actual video you start to
make and then you become known
as the girl the go-to girl for x
and after you break through jay then you
can start making videos about whatever
you want because you'll start to have
built enough influence
past the point of proficiency where
people want to know about your everyday
life and they want to know about how
cool your bedroom is and all those
different things so
does that give you some some pieces some
handles around how to start
on youtube yeah awesome and you asked
about how to promote it
yeah um we have what's called the 50 50
rule of content
which means that if you're gonna spend
two to four to eight hours
making a video i want you to block on
your calendar
two to four to eight hours that you
spend
in the community helping people on the
dms in twitter
liking people's stuff because when you
give
on social you get back okay so if you're
out there and you're actually just in
the community
rather than it being like how can i get
more i want you to twist it and say how
can i give more
okay okay awesome thank you that help
yes great well hey are you registered
for
the challenge jay yes yes awesome well
we'll see you next tuesday then
see you guys bye thank you appreciate
your day thanks for coming on
all right hey think marketing q a it's
awesome
that uh jay's so awesome it's good to
see uh jen
uh good to see you rick thanks so much
for being here live or if you're
watching on the replay we've got some
more questions to answer
and uh we want to help you do this by
the way every other week on this youtube
channel and across facebook
we um are going live and helping you
win on youtube helping you win with
building your business get more views
get more influence
with online video and social media we do
a show called coffee with kennel every
other week which is my
coffee q a show and then melissa
and heather typically are doing the
think marketing q a sometimes tony
and we come to talk about youtube and
talk about how you can build your
influence in your brand online
faster and so i really appreciate you
being here if you've got a question
throw up uh four question marks before
and after it and if you want to jump on
the show
uh the room is full but we'll get to as
many as we can
today let's bring patrick on the show
patrick
where are you watching from what's up
california
where where in california glendora
glendora great to have you on and what's
your channel about
um i'm a licensed mental health
therapist and so i've
started off with a podcast earlier this
year in a blog last year and so i kind
of discovered youtube
this year mostly through your channel
thank you so much
and so i'm really trying to bring them
all three together
so that i can um kind of mirror all
three content so i've
what i've started doing is i'll take the
blog and then i'll do like a
a video podcast and then i'll use the
same audio for both
kind of like i've seen with the think
marketing channel and some other stuff
but where i'm getting a little bit hung
up is do i create
pillar content like i'm in the habit of
with the podcast
or do i break it up into smaller chunks
with the youtube
and then negotiating the whole keyword
you know title with the blog should it
be the same
title with the video and i think you
could just kind of touched on that a
little bit
so i really appreciate all of the advice
i really do
yeah so if i understand i think that the
question is
to clarify you have a long-form video
podcast and you also are considering
doing snippets of the video podcast
all on youtube in this case and and then
how to title those that content
right yeah so for example like i'm
getting ready to create uh
an episode on coping skills for anxiety
and i could talk about three things 10
skills 20 skills
or should i break those up into smaller
like one skill
per video that makes sense
yeah yeah so um a couple nuances here
um and that is it definitely
uh things we've learned between short
form and long-form content
so one of the things that's interesting
about doing a video podcast and we're
now
about eight months into that with um
because of the think marketing podcast
that launched this year
what i've learned and we also have an
interview show on video influencers i've
actually learned that for long form
content
you don't want to title your videos
to you don't want to over promise like a
quick answer in your title because
here's the thing on youtube that works
really good right
like how to do this thing really fast
and the secret to youtube
is making a promise in your title and
then delivering on that promise
so if you for instance were gonna be
like how to
set up your youtube channel and someone
looked at the the title and saw that the
or the video and they saw was five
minutes long
and then they saw there was a 50 minute
long version i'd rather watch the five
minute long version
so for example on video influencers we
do longer form conversations now on
saturday for the vi
show and what i've learned is that if we
make it too tactical
it's not effective because a shorter
video would be much better tactical so
i don't know if this is what you're
after but i think this strategy is
important if it's a longer form video
it's nice to kind of say like like
promise a journey like a conversation
with heather taurus about
how she built her youtube channel so
people kind of know what they're getting
the key is you want to make a promise in
the title
and then deliver it in the video whereas
on the other hand the snippets
i think is really identifying even what
snippets to post
is being really specific and sniper on
one problem one solution be brief be
bright be fun and be done like
so what we do nowadays and this is kind
of a cool experiment that we've been
doing is we're doing a lot of what's
called content recycling and also
repurposing
and it's working incredibly well because
we'll do we're doing it right now we're
doing a longer form show it's going to
be about an hour here
on youtube and it's going to do well but
it's not going to do phenomenal because
the replay value of an hour long video
is not super great but on think media
we'll take them
the hottest moments the most concise
clear moments
from coffee with cannell the think
marketing q a show
and upload list look at this one five
minutes of 53 seconds
there's heather teaching on the one
video you should make if you're under a
thousand subscribers and it got 90k
views the hour-long version obviously
this channel is newer and different
subscribers
but it got you know 5 000 views and
that's all relative to kind of where
you're starting
we'll take coffee with candle episodes
do one question one
answer in five minutes so
again i want to see if i actually
answered your question and maybe i can
hit your question specifically
but i think that's a relevant strategy
for what you're doing in general
to be thinking about maybe a consistent
show we post once a week
and people get used to it also doesn't
get nearly as many views as the short
specific things because the nature of
youtube
even watch time and whatnot is usually
like i'm in i want my question answered
i want to be entertained
get me to the point quick hook me and
and podcasts are usually longer form
they're more about intimacy they're more
like you're on a walk
you're out with your dog you're at the
gym so even the audio is gonna perform
different
so the the strategy between longer form
and shorter form is gonna influence your
title strategy is that helpful patrick
oh absolutely i think the last video i
made was 90 minutes on
six ways to improve self-care but i i
think what i want to start doing after
listening to you and thank you so much
for taking my question
is just breaking up the content into
like you said more digestible
chunks so like a 10 minute to 30 minute
video and i could still post that on the
podcast but maybe
instead of doing like if it's a shorter
video maybe instead of posting it once a
week maybe do it twice
a week smaller chunks you know yeah 100
i think that's a great strategy all
right thank you so much
i'm just i didn't know you're doing this
today i was i was between therapy
sessions and i thought hey you know
i saw the email so i jumped right on i
really appreciate it
you know i watched amazing please
challenge it's already been
a huge plus so thank you so much awesome
patrick
yay awesome thanks patrick yeah and uh
here's a tip for our whole think media
think marketing
community when you're starting and even
when you're established
lean on shorter content because it's
kind of the idea
like has anyone don't don't answer in
the comments unless you want to
like if you're just getting to know
somebody and you're in your dating
season of life
like if you usually don't just meet
somebody and you're like hey nice to
meet you
let's go on a two-week road trip like
that's it's like i just met him i don't
know if i'm gonna be able to handle
a two-week week road trip with the
person if
you're really just getting to know
somebody it's like speed dating you know
in fact speed dating is a chance to i've
never actually done it but
you would go through and and you're
getting it's like bite-sized digestible
to even see if you want to go to the
next level with that person
and even at the next level you still
after maybe you go on a short day it's
like yo let's get some coffee
let's have a little conversation and
let's call it good i don't necessarily
don't need to go get
coffee go get a four-course meal walk
around the city
and watch two movies like i'm just can
we slow it down like let's
you know kind of have a different pace
on this relationship think about
people's customer
journey or rather their viewer journey
or their getting to know you journey
when it comes to the brand and business
that you're building online
give people a chance to get to know you
with more short form
be brief be bright be fun
and be done and then there's people who
will as they get to know you they see
that there's value there or they
resonate with you they vibe with you
and then they want to hang out longer
and then maybe it's like let's go on a
road trip and they're like cool like
i've seen your short stuff i'm like
ready to go on like do a longer session
a longer training off of youtube uh you
know
longer videos and so 90 minutes
patrick's doing some amazing stuff
there's some amazing value in there but
i think that's kind of the edge
is to also give people to quickly
deliver
value as quick as possible how we had a
question
how long should my videos be when
starting if you can keep it under 10 i
think that's strong if you can keep it
under 5
that's even stronger if you can deliver
value in 3 minutes under eight minutes
and the video should be as long as they
need to be but as short as possible
but give people a chance to speed date
you see if they connect with you
and then at the end of your video always
give a call to action hey if you got
value out of this video
and you want to watch the full
conversation click or tap the screen
it's kind of like an appetizer an hors
d'oeuvre
and they taste it and then they could
watch the 90-minute version it could be
the thing you link to at the end
because now they're like well i want to
see this whole thing unpacked take me
through
the whole psychology journey patrick but
maybe they come in
with just a bite size answer and so
when starting definitely start with the
shorter questions hey if you're getting
value today hit like we got
carly coming on the think marketing
show arleigh where are you watching from
what's your channel about and how can we
help
i am watching from durham north carolina
and my channel is all about pregnancy
and
labor and uh postpartum period
um and i started the beginning of this
year
and i feel like i've been doing a lot of
the right things i feel like i
am doing a lot of the seo research i'm
talking about stuff that i know people
are searching
for and i feel like my growth is still
pretty slow
so i'm wondering what tips you might
have to kind of improve
that growth i'm gonna have heather
answer this but what is your channel
name i looked up your first and last
name could it find it
it's harvest moon nights it's my doula
company
so i just want to make sure carly it's a
growth question like how do i grow
yeah because i feel like a lot of the
things that i'm doing i follow a lot of
the
tips that you guys put out and i feel
like i am doing all the things that i
can do
but the growth feels a little slow for
how much work i'm putting in
yeah yeah um 500 subscribers already
yeah which is very exciting yes i was
gonna say can we just
congratulate you on that because
sometimes i think carly
we think about you know oh i'm not
getting millions of views and i get i
fall into this too
so i mean these numbers they matter but
can we just give it up for this right
here this is an analytic that we're
getting from vid iq i don't know if you
have this installed on your channel
but you had 5 000 moms
visit your page 5
000 like can we put that into
perspective of what that would be like
if you walked into a seminar right now
a stadium 5 000 people
watched your channel so i know it can
feel like this isn't getting off the
ground i'm putting in a lot of work
carly it is a lot of work and you got to
put in a lot of work
and the reason that you're going to
break through is because
once you just stay consistent and you
keep serving and you keep helping
you're going to get to this tipping
point and it's going to break through
it takes one video it takes one video
carly
to blow your channel up you have one
video we've seen this happen
over and over and over again we call
them bass hits right now you're making
videos they're base hits this is my
baseball analogy i don't really i don't
know baseball but this is my only
baseball analogy
you're just making bass hits right and
you just keep swinging you keep swinging
the bass hit and then
all of a sudden you hit that one and it
gets that
sweet spot of the bat and it's like over
the outfield and out of the park and
then all of a sudden
that video is going to trickle down and
people are going to see your other
videos and your other videos in your
other videos
and i completely understand it's like oh
this feels like so much
work and it really is like there's
nothing
around that it really is so how do you
grow how do you do more
of what we're teaching here at think
media and think marketing
i want you to have you studied your
competition
have you gone to your competition and
you're like you know what
these are their top 10 videos wow every
single person makes this video
have you made that video when we think
about
what video should i make next here's
what i want you to do what are the top
25 to 50 questions
that people are asking and the reason
i'm saying this is because one of the
things we miss so much is we want to
make
the videos of all videos right we want
to be like how to
how to like be in the postpartum stage
of life and
like that's what we're trying to like
get to but really they just want to know
like should i get this breast pump or
this breast pump
they want to know like do i need this
breast bag or you know like breast pump
bag or this breast pump back
do i freeze it do i not do i swaddle
like this do i not like sean's about to
step into this not that he's in
postpartum but i i feel you i know this
life i've done it
twice already uh but he's not asking
sonia his wife is not necessarily she
doesn't know what she doesn't know
carly but what she knows is how do i get
my baby to sleep
how do i feed my how do i transition
from salt from breast milk to solid food
how do i do self-care how do like how do
i
how do i um find clothes that are uh
nursing friendly like does that make
sense so as much as i
i know that your heart is to really
impact
uh moms with that knowledge about
postpartum
their pain point is this nursing bra or
this nursing bra
does that make sense oh yeah definitely
so how do you grow as i want you to
write down
what are the 25 to 50 questions
that they're actually asking right now
in that stage of life like
the real hard like what essential oils
do i need
for can i put on my baby like what uh
what um
bath products do i use like all of those
things that you
know and you're like doesn't everyone
know this like they seem so
simple and and kind of stupid like
doesn't everyone know that you shouldn't
use toxins on your baby like
no they don't carly and they need you to
help them know that okay
so i want you to be doing that and i
want you to study your competition
go to the other five pages that are like
what you're making
go to their top videos and see the
trends
and when you see those trends i want you
to make those videos with the carly spin
on them
awesome great absolutely no because i've
definitely
i think that's kind of the path that
i've followed so far is going for those
big hitting videos but i definitely
haven't focused on
kind of smaller pinpointed questions
like that so that is definitely
fantastic advice
and like sean said short videos five
minutes
uh what are the two you know i mean we
can go on and on i could
i love postpartum this is my jam too i
was like if i could be a doula it would
probably be my next job but
but you know what about what about the
fourth trimester do they
or the fifth trimester do they need to
know can you eat your placenta like yeah
i mean this is
do you know what i mean like yeah see
like shawn's like what i didn't even
know like
do you encapsulate or do you cook it
like you know
yeah and carly here's the other thing to
remember it's
called the total addressable market how
many people are actually searching these
things right
millions i don't know if millions of
moms yet are
searching for that exact thing about
placenta encapsulation
but there's a market that is and when
that market is thriving
you can join that conversation so i
would also just remember that even
like we're in the tech space we get
millions of views on tech
but i'm in the homeschool space i'm
happy if i get a hundred thousand
because it's just the total addressable
market of what that
uh actual um tribe is searching for
online but carly
i want to honor you for the work that
you're doing because i know it's hard
and
gosh you are in such a beautiful place
to help so many moms in 2020
through all the craziness that's
happening right now so i just want to
say thank you for the work that you're
doing and
keep going your brand looks beautiful
right sean like you pulled that up
and i was like that's that looks good i
love the undertones and all
like really really nice the earthy feel
to it so
yeah great job you're doing great
awesome i appreciate it guys
yeah carly and i just want to encourage
you as well even those that were here
live with us were even saying like
wow like congrats carly like look at
that subscriber count so it's all
perspective and just to bring up this
page
again and this is a little stats tab
that vid iq gives us
like when i see green when i see 59
growth in views 68 growth in subscribers
it's actually kind of crazy to think
like i hope my bank account goes up
59 i mean a lot of people are like i
hope like
my muscle mass goes up 68
and so growth is something that of
course we should measure especially if
like
these are good numbers to look at are
they going down are they going up
and then how what's winning you know
success leaves clues
what are my top what's my top viewed
video and how can i repeat that
and and double down on what's working so
are you also part of the uh challenge
yeah i am cool you're gonna man we're
gonna go so deep you're gonna have a lot
of fun and so
grateful for you i'm glad we were able
to connect on here excited thanks so
much you guys i really really appreciate
it
you're welcome carly all right well hey
think marketing q a uh appreciate you
hit the like button
um a couple other questions and then
we'll land the plane
here um but before we do heather what is
the youtube influence challenge and why
should people be a part of it
really great question sean and i loved
your face by the way when i
said placenta because you're like wait
what are we talking about
me and carly are jamming on that um okay
the uh
youtube influence challenge guys if you
fall into one of these two categories
you want to start
or you want to grow a youtube channel
this is the place you need to be
during the youtube influence challenge
this is a seven day
free challenge that myself sean cannell
and the think media team
are going to be hosting inside of a
private group so it's not happening here
online you have to sign
up for this challenge and during these
seven days we're going to be going
live two times a day to be teaching you
through
our seven step system this is a
proprietary process we call it the 7r
framework where we teach this inside of
our 2 000
course video ranking academy we're
giving it away for free sean are we
crazy we're giving away for free
out during this challenge so here's the
thing
we're going to be walking through these
seven r's these seven r's have generated
millions of views these are ours that
you can apply to your channel if you're
an influencer an
entrepreneur a creator a business owner
if you know
someone that is one of these and they
need to get on youtube
how about you and them sign up for the
seven day challenge but here's what i'm
excited about
we're gonna be doing some insane
giveaways
we are going to be giving away things
like an entire youtube studio
like we're talking camera microphone
lighting
everything with that we're going to be
giving away subscriptions to vid iq
and epidemic sound epidemic sound is one
of the
main music sources we use here on
youtube
you're you're going to have the
opportunity to win that as well we're
going to be giving away
um memberships to thinkific so if you're
going to be starting a course this year
and you want to
help your audience you could get a free
membership to that so many great things
are going to be happening
during this seven-day challenge and if
you raise your hand and say
yeah i want to start or i want to grow
my youtube channel this year
this is the challenge for you if you've
felt like you needed
community here on youtube if you feel
like you're kind of doing this thing
alone
then this is the challenge for you we've
got over 10 000 purpose-driven
entrepreneurs
just like you already signed up and
registered the group is on
fire so much conversation and connection
and community i mean it's
like i i'm addicted to being in there
right now because people are just having
such great
conversations and i'm just i cannot wait
for the next seven days because
when we start this it is um last time we
did it we had people say this changed my
life
i mean a youtube challenge changed their
life because
we're sharing with you the exact process
that sean used
to go from filming videos in his bedroom
to
running a multiple seven-figure media
company
and growing multiple youtube channels to
over a million subscribers so
this isn't just you know something we're
throwing together this is a process that
he's been perfecting
for a decade and we're sharing it with
you for free
on the youtube influence challenge you
can sign up at tubeinfluence.com
and then here's my challenge to you we
know that good people you're good people
right we know that good people know good
people and so
you probably have someone right now that
came to mind when i said that that
you're like
man he needs to get on youtube why is he
not on youtube yet
like you know that business owner in
your life your uncle your friend
that person sean i can think of two
people right now i'm gonna
actually send a text message to and say
hey we're doing this challenge
i really think you should be there
because it's free there's no obligation
you sign up you get to join the group
it's free
we have different things for you if you
want to take your experience to the next
level
but you can experience everything for
seven days fully free
with the entire think media group i
cannot wait sean
i am on fire because of all the
conversations that are happening inside
of the group yeah i'm so excited as well
heather and worship with ladies
says where can we sign up you just go to
the website
tube influence dot
and there's a link in the description
below or refresh the video and you'll
see a link in the description below
but if you type that into safari or
google chrome you go there and all the
information to sign up is on
that page it starts officially so you
have time to kind of get ready
maybe even work on your schedule to
really be there it starts on the 18th of
august
and it's seven days and we're taking
sunday off so it kind of goes into the
next week
every single day there's a session at 10
a.m
los angeles time west coast time
pacific time 10 a.m and
4 p.m two sessions of the day 12
sessions total
entirely free and so a lot of some
people are either
blocking time to take time off work
rearrange their schedule give the kids
to their partner
um doing things like scheduling that
even if they have to work when are they
going to watch the replays
and all those different things you've
got some time to get your journal
to get your sticky notes to get some
pens to get your mind right your grind
on
dust your camera off get a little
plug-in mic whatever you want to do to
get ready
because it's all starting in just a few
days
and so um super excited for that and
um one final question that we just
wanted to answer
uh stavic valla i hope i said your name
right
has a great question he said you know do
you suggest
having a niche name for your youtube
channel or just your name
like for example is my channel name okay
and it looks like your channel name is
your first and last name
i think that is okay i do think though
that having a niche
is powerful in your channel name and so
here's your three options
you either go your first and last name
or something to do with just your first
name if you don't want to share your
last name
or i suppose like a pen name kind of
like if you want to keep your identity
private people do do that and i think it
can be a smart move
depending on your values or what you're
trying to do
second option is a hybrid you could say
like
strength training with stavic like if it
was a fitness channel
and i think that's a real powerful thing
to do like cooking with carla like
because then people know what the
channel is about and there's a little
bit of personality in there
or finally you go brand name only niche
and like think media think think
marketing is a great example this very
youtube channel
is like what's the channel about not
cooking what's the channel about
homeschool
nope it's in the name marketing and
having a brand name gives us a chance
also
to have a team and to have not only
guests on of course you could have
guests on your personal brand or even a
team on your personal brand
but you know heather's training on here
melissa caputo
tony areola by the way they're all going
to be in the youtube challenge sharing
quick tips of the day
and doing giveaways and doing a lot of
cool stuff and so those are kind of your
options and i think you're good to go
with what you have but for everybody
watching that's curious about how to
name your channel
you know i think just pick one and run
with it and um
remember that you can always change it
meaning it's not hard to
like heather's is heather taurus she
could say homeschooling with heather
taurus like you could just add that like
you can you know you don't change your
name a lot
it'll confuse youtube potentially and
you want it to kind of
be in google as far as seo and search
but if she felt like adding
a hybrid and saying homeschooling with
heather taurus easy
and then there's also maybe some seo and
some search that can be related to that
so
hey hit the like button if you got value
today uh this video is brought to you by
the
tube influence challenge if you're just
hearing about it link in the description
below and then of course
um if you're just joining and you're
looking for those three irresistible
youtube titles watch the replay on this
video because heather
brought some really practical youtube
titles that'll help you
get more views we appreciate you so much
thank you
uh tara tara samuel and jake we look
forward to hopefully getting you on one
of the next shows
or on the q a that we're going to be
doing in the youtube influence challenge
i'll see y'all for coffee with kennel
next week here on think marketing and in
the meantime
keep crushing it and we will talk soon